wir müssen alles dafür tun den
menschengemachten klimawandel
aufzuhalten jetzt gibt es keine ausreden
mehr wir wissen jetzt ins handeln beim
klimaschutz
das ist ja die bilanz der letzten jahre
dass wir oft ehrgeizige ambitionierte
ziele haben die aber dann auf dem papier
stehen bleiben das flut drama im aartal
hat es auch dem letzten vor augen
geführt die katastrophe kommt nein sie
ist an vielen stellen schon da dringend
einen unser leben selbst in der
scheinbar sicheren eifel es ist
offensichtlich dass wir massiv umsteuern
ist die erkenntnis ist längst da und
dennoch tun viele von uns nicht nur die
politik viel zu wenig warum ist das
warum lassen wir uns mehr zeit als wir
haben das wollen wir uns in den nächsten
minuten näher anschauen ich bin theo
koll willkommen bei context
wir steuern ganz offensichtlich auf die
klima kipp punkte zu danach ist nichts
mehr aufzuhalten die wissenschaft warnt
uns menschen seit jahrzehnten genau vor
dieser entwicklung aber warum ist so
wenig passiert sind regierungen zu
kurzsichtig sind wir bürger zu bequem
die wirtschaft zu profitorientiert
kontext möchte genau das liefern die
nötigen kontext also hintergrund zu
aktuellen fragen und debatten beginnen
wir mit der deutschen klima und
umweltpolitik generell gehen wir davon
aus dass die temperaturen bis zur
zweiten hälfte des nächsten jahrhunderts
um 1,5 bis 4,5 grad celsius erhöhen
werden die folge wird eine zunahme der
meteorologischen extremsituationen seien
unter anderem auch der frequenz und der
intensität von stürmen das war 1990 also
vor über 30 jahren die warnungen vor dem
drohenden klimawandel klingen heute
erstaunlich ähnlich etwa im jüngsten
sachstandsbericht des weltklimarats
zeigen in diesem bericht sehr klar dass
jedes zehn grad erwärmung zusätzliche
extreme mit sich bringt insbesondere ist
in das hitzewellen und damit verbundene
dürren aber auch extrem niederschläge
werden häufiger durch zunahme des
klimawandels
weltweiten co2 emissionen steigen weiter
allen warnungen zum trotz
in deutschland schaffen wir es zwar den
nationalen treibhausgas ausstoß seit
1990 tendenziell leicht zu senken doch
alles viel zu langsam wenn ich mir die
situation anschaut kann kein mensch
sagen dass der genug getan haben dass da
vollkommen klar aber das kann kenne ich
auch echt im augenblick niemand frau
merkel bezieht uns alle ein keiner habe
genug getan aber warum ist das so das
wollen wir uns näher ansehen und gehen
dafür kurz zurück in die 90er jahre
bundesrepublik nimmt
die ihr eigenes klimaziel ernst sie sagt
nicht nur was für andere gilt dann auch
für sie die industrieländer müssen die
leistungen beim klimaschutz bringen
damals ende der neunziger gilt
deutschland als musterschüler im fach
klimaschutz wir sind zwar damals der
fünftgrößte verursacher von
klimaschädlichen gasen zeigen aber
zumindest die bereitschaft die mission
zu reduzieren und kämpfen auf
internationalen gipfeln eifrig für mehr
klimaschutz und so auch 1997 bei den
verhandlungen des kyoto protokolls der
man mit optimismus an die sache rangehen
will da muss man auch an den erfolg
glauben ich denke es gibt eine reale
chance aber es wäre extrem schwierige
verhandlungen aber ich werde mich
bemühen wenn es ein protokoll gibt auf
basis des us vorschlags wird deutschland
dem zustimmen also für mich ist ein
ergebnis dieser verhandlungen
das heißt stabilisierung und keine zahl
für reduktion kein ergebnis dem werde
ich nicht zustimmen als umweltministerin
hatte angela merkel eine klare und
ambitionierte haltung zum umwelt und
klimaschutz stieß aber schnell an die
grenzen ihrer macht welche konsequenzen
aus dem sommersmog zu ziehen sind bleibt
in deutschland umstritten
umweltministerin merkel plädiert wie
auch die spd für fahrverbote dies
scheiterte allerdings im bonner kabinett
am veto vom wirtschafts und
verkehrsminister eigentlich wollte sich
angela merkel vom kabinett die eckwerte
ihrer sommersmog verordnung bestätigen
lassen großräumige und umfassende
fahrverbote sowie den dazugehörigen ozon
grenzwerte
doch dann ließ die ministerin die schon
angekündigte pressekonferenz auf einmal
platzen offensichtlich war die
umweltministerin mit ihren vorstellungen
bei zwei kollegen aufgelaufen aus forst
über die blockadehaltung ihrer eigenen
parteikollegen soll die umweltministerin
merkel in der kabinettssitzung sogar in
tränen ausgebrochen sein heißt es später
in den zeitungen aber nicht nur sie
scheitert mit konkreten
klimaschutzmaßnahmen beispielsweise 2004
als die regierung schröder ein
partikelfilter für den diesel
verpflichtend machen wollte die deutsche
automobilindustrie zögert mit der
einführung von rußpartikel filtern sie
fürchtet dass
partikelfilter unter jedem fahrzeug
möglicherweise bei kleinen fahrzeugen
mit fahrzeugen die fahrzeuge relativ
teuer machen und damit daneben
möglicherweise aufgrund dieser
verteuerung diese fahrzeuge nicht mehr
der diesel-version
nachgefragt werden die autobranche
bremste so lange bei den partikelfiltern
bis sie schließlich links und rechts
überholt wurde verbraucher und
verbraucherinnen wollten ihren neuwagen
nicht mehr ohne filter oder der
sogenannte veggie day die idee der
grünen im wahlkampf jahr 2013 einen
fleischfreien tag in öffentlichen
kantinen einzuführen ein buggy day in
den kantinen in der woche als
möglichkeit ist ein großer schritt für
das was wir wollen wenn es um die
beendigung von massentierhaltung geht
die reaktionen von medien aber auch der
anderen parteien fallen teils heftig aus
und jetzt wissen sie entscheidend ist es
für sie und ihr leben wichtiger
dass ihnen jemand sagt dass sie
donnerstags kein fleisch essen soll
oder ist es für sie und ihr leben
wichtiger dass wir nicht mehr mehr als
fünf millionen arbeitslose haben sondern
dass wir weniger als drei millionen
arbeitslose dabei ist die meinung
innerhalb der bevölkerung gar nicht mal
so eindeutig wie die empörung aus den
medien und anderen parteien vermuten
lässt einer repräsentativen umfrage
zufolge unterstützt damals eine knappe
mehrheit der deutschen sogar die idee
eines valley days jedenfalls sagen sie
das aber auch aus anderen fällen kennt
die wissenschaft des phänomen sozial
erwünschte antworten denn gleichzeitig
zeigt dieselbe studie eine mehrheit der
deutschen meint der staat solle eine
fleischlose ernährung nicht bevor
bei der anschließenden bundestagswahl
2013 fahren die grünen prompt ein
schlechtes ergebnis ein die kehrtwende
beim thema veggie day lässt nicht lange
auf sich warten also der parteitag auf
dem ich gerade bin und den ich jetzt
aufmerksam verfolgt hat der hat gerade
eben beschlossen dass wir keinen patch
idee mehr fordern sondern dass wir
künftig auch nicht darüber reden wollen
was die leute essen klimaschutz ist uns
deutschen in der theorie hochwillkommen
aber wenn es an unsere liebgewonnenen
gewohnheiten geht an unseren geldbeutel
oder an unseren komfort dann ist es
schnell vorbei mit den guten vorsätzen
ich beispielsweise könnte jeden tag mit
dem fahrrad zur arbeit fährt die faktur
aber greife ich zwei von drei mal zum
autoschlüssel und weil es regnet oder
das gepäck angeblich zu schwer ist sich
mit dem auto einige minuten schneller
bin oder bruder ich habe mehr ausreden
als das kilometer ins studio sind und
wenn man sich zb anschaut dass sich der
anteil an neuzulassungen für suvs seit
2015 fast verdoppelt hat dann ist es
kein wunder dass sich politiker und
politikerinnen so schwer damit tun
strikte klimaschutz maßnahmen zu
ergreifen sie fürchten sie welche daten
die reaktion der wähler das ist die eine
sicht auf die tatenlosigkeit die andere
ist die so genannte strategie der
tatenlose so nennt der klimaforscher
michael man die taktik großer konzerne
und kohle fördern dass staaten wie
australien die verantwortung zu
individualisiert der einzelne soll das
gefühl bekommen erstmal bei sich selber
anfangen zu müssen weniger fleisch zu
essen weniger auto zu fahren weniger zu
fliegen dabei gehen aber 70 prozent der
treibhausgasemissionen auf das konto von
nur etwa 100 unternehmen aus dem bereich
kohle öl und gas das soll jetzt nicht
heißen dass der einzelne keine
verantwortung übernehmen muss aber ein
genauerer blick auf die großen
klimaschädlichen player in deutschland
und ihren einfluss auf die politik lohnt
sich es ist doch wirklich nicht redlich
für die zukunft des weltklimas die
automobilhersteller in
investitionen hinein zu treiben wie sie
letztlich gar nicht materiell und auch
wirtschaftlich leisten können
insbesondere die industrie hat es immer
wieder geschafft sich mit geschickten
lobbyisten und klugen argumenten in der
politik gehör zu verschaffen zwei
bezeichnende fälle aus den vergangenen
jahren lohnen das genaue hinschauen im
sommer 2013 will der umweltausschuss der
eu die abgasgrenzwerte für neue autos
stärker begrenzen nach langen
verhandlungen steht schließlich ein deal
bis 2020 sollen neuwagen pro kilometer
nur noch 95 gramm des schädlichen
klimagases freisetzen bislang waren es
130 die autolobby ist alarmiert doch als
drohte kompromiss ohne weitere
aufweichungen der grenzwerte
verabschiedet werden soll steigt angela
merkel auf die politische bremse vor
allem die deutschen premiumhersteller
daimler bmw und audi die meist große
limousinen herstellen fühlen sich von
den europäischen plänen benachteiligt
nachteile der deutschen
automobilindustrie will die kanzlerin
aber nicht hinnehmen persönlich
intervenierte sie in brüssel
schlussendlich schaffte es angela merkel
den beschluss der neuen grenzwerte
hinauszuzögern und gleich auch noch
ausnahmen für die grenzwerte festzulegen
der fall zeigt wie fest das band
zwischen automobil industrie und politik
ist zumindest mal war da liegt mir
wieder ganz besonders die
automobilindustrie am herzen dabei ist
schon ganz klar dass das automobil
industrie politisch die
halsschlagader von rolf lang in bayern
ist man hat manchmal wirklich das gefühl
dass die deutschen autobauer ihre
regierung komplett in der hand haben die
bundesregierung hat hier in brüssel
schon oft eu entscheidungen im interesse
der hersteller beeinflusst
ebenfalls ein erfolg der wirtschaft mehr
noch einer ganz anderen industrie war
der 2016 verhandelte kohlekompromiss da
geht es um kohle die nämlich verdirbt
deutschlands vorreiterrolle in puncto
klimaschutz die co2 emissionen aus der
stromerzeugung stiegen zuletzt deutlich
an und so ruft der wirtschaftsminister
heute eine abkehr von der kohle aus
besonders alte und umweltschädliche
kraftwerke wollte wirtschaftsminister
gabriel mit einer strafabgabe belegen
der klimabeitrag hat aus unserer sicht
den vorteil dass er effizient und
kostengünstig ist noch 2014 port sigmar
gabriel vehement auf die von ihm
vorgeschlagene klimaabgabe doch gegen
diese idee stellen sich sowohl die
kohlekraftwerke als auch die
gewerkschaften und schaffen es die
strafabgabe sogar in eine art prämie für
alte kohlekraftwerke umzuwandeln
stattdessen bekommen die unternehmen
jetzt geld dafür dass die kraftwerke
stilllegen aber für notfälle
betriebsbereit halten sind ja
weitestgehend auf den vorschlag der ig
bce der gewerkschaft eingegangen haben
sie sich darüber tisch ziehen ach nein
wir sind darauf eingegangen dass die
gewerkschaften und die arbeitgeber
gemeinsam gesagt haben wenn er das alte
modell nehmen dass wir eigentlich
vorhatten der kohle abgabe dann wird es
zur struktur abbrüchen kommen mit
tausenden von arbeitslosen die
argumentation der industrie dass die
produkte für die kunden zu teuer werden
oder dass arbeitsplätze verloren und
ganze industriebranchen niedergehen ist
nicht neu unternehmen und lobby verbände
haben dieselben argumente schon häufig
angebracht sobald neue
klimaschutzmaßnahmen droht natürlich ist
die sicherung von arbeitsplätzen und des
industriestandortes deutschland wichtig
aber häufig ist es auch nur ein allzu
bequemes argument konkrete
klimaschutzmaßnahmen auszubremsen
natürlich gab es auch momente in denen
erstaunlich konkrete schritte in kurzer
zeit gelungen sind das montrealer
protokoll von 1987 ist so ein beispiel
damals schaffte es die
staatengemeinschaft auf einen schlag und
schädliche gase fckw zu begrenzen es ist
nicht falsch manchmal zum ordnungsrecht
zugreifen das verbot von fckw es war das
erfolgreichste verbot aller zeiten seit
dem schließt sich das ozonloch wenn die
maßnahmen einfach durchzusetzen sind
entweder weil sie den bürgern und
bürgerinnen nicht viel abverlangen oder
weil die notwendigkeit der verbote
unmittelbar einzusehen ist wie im fall
des fckw verbots dann kann es auch mal
ganz schnell gehen mit dem klimaschutz
haben sie manchmal angst dass ihr kind
nicht mehr die sonne schicken können
könnte schon sein es hat ja jetzt schon
sehr schöne kinderkriegen unheimlich
schnellen sollen dann kann ja jetzt
schon selten doch raus lassen das glaube
ich schon glaube schon ganz zu wollen
nur leider gibt es viel zu wenige
solcher positivbeispiele die quittung
für ihre unzureichende klimapolitik hat
die bundesregierung jetzt vom
bundesverfassungsgericht bekommen die
obersten richter erklärten im april 2021
eines klimaschutzgesetz von 2009 10 für
in teilen verfassungswidrig
die bundesregierung lege keinen
konkreten plan für die zeit nach 2030
vor und das gefährde die freiheit
kommender generationen
das großartige an diesem ich kann es gar
nicht sagen anders seinen coolen spruch
des bundesverfassungsgerichts ist das
ist eigentlich übersetzt folgendes
gesagt ziele haben ist ja schön sagen
wie es geht ist noch viel besser
warum hast du es nicht gemacht als
vizekanzler
mittlerweile hat die bundesregierung
reagiert und die klimaziele erhöht unter
anderem soll deutschland nun schon 2045
treibhausgas neutral werden doch selbst
das reicht nicht um für deutschland die
pariser klimaziele einzuhalten der
weltklimarat hat es durchgerechnet und
für deutschland lautet das ergebnis die
zahl die wir berechnet haben 6,7
milliarden tonnen an co2 emission die
wir insgesamt uns noch erlauben dürfen
die würde wenn wir eine lineare abnahme
der emissionen annehmen bis zum jahr
2038 reichen ein blick in die
vergangenheit zeigt dass politiker und
politikerinnen am ehesten dann rasch
handeln wenn katastrophen die menschen
aufrütteln und auch wir selber müssen
uns ehrlich machen warum brauchen wir
erst eine unmittelbare bedrohung bevor
wir klimamaßnahmen akzeptieren oder
sogar umsetzen dass die flutkatastrophe
des sommers die waldbrände in vielen
teilen europas oder auch der druck durch
die freude es verfügt hat demonstranten
dann doch das politische tempo
entscheidend steigern werden scheint
angesichts der bisherigen erfahrungen
leider eine allzu optimistische hoffnung
handelt als würde ein haus brennt es
denn dass gutes
die kasse des welche wichtigen maßnahmen
muss die ampel regierung umsetzen und
wie kann jeder einzelne zu mehr
klimaschutz animiert wird schreiben sie
es mir gerne hier in die kommentare
wenn sie mehr kontext sehen wollen
abonnieren sie den kanal und wenn sie
ein anderes video von meinen kolleginnen
und kollegen im zdf sehen wollen klicken
sie einfach hier